salut dans cette vidéo vous allez voir
que vous confondez des couleurs que vous
ne savez pas faire la différence entre
le noir et le blanc parfois que vous
entendez des sons qui n'existent pas
bref que votre cerveau a une conception
bien à lui de ce qu'est réel et de ce
qu'il ne l'est pas vous avez parfois
l'impression que le monde est bizarre
c'est à cause de votre cerveau désolé
vos perceptions vos émotions vos
sensations etc sont manipulées et c'est
tout aussi étonnant que flippant j'ai
choisi comme décor le Musée d'Art de
Nantes parce qu'il y a en ce moment
l'exposition hyper sensible l'expo
fascinante sur l'hyperréalisme dont les
œuvres vont nous servir d'exemple à côté
de moi ce n'est pas une femme toute nue
évidemment il s'agit d'une sculpture
hyper réaliste de type Toland
l'hyperréalisme consiste à réaliser une
oeuvre tellement réaliste que votre
cerveau n'arrive pas à savoir si c'est
vrai ou s'il s'agit d'une peinture ou
d'une sculpture c'est incroyable les
yeux sont écarquillés la bouche est
gonflée d'air on peut sentir un petit
peu la tension en fait de ces jours on
peut même ressentir le côté un peu
flasque de sa peau la finesse de son
grain de peau mais est-ce que vous êtes
certain de ce que vous voyez les ombres
par exemple est-ce qu'elles sont réelles
ou est-ce qu'elles sont
évidemment corrigé ce défaut en faisant
une balance des blancs pour déterminer
la couleur réelle à savoir bleu et noir
qui était sa vraie couleur en deuxième
exemple une expérience similaire avait
été faite avec une paire de baskets
alors est-ce qu'elle est rose ou est-ce
qu'elle est verte d'après vous là encore
vous pouvez observer que la main qui
tient la chaussure n'a pas du tout la
même température de lumière sur la
basket rose la main est presque rouge
tandis que sur la basket verte la main
est presque froide ou en tout cas elle
est très froide d'autres expériences
aussi fascinantes ont été montré au
public tels que les dérivés de
l'échiquier d'adelson sur cette
échiquier vous allez voir en haut des
pièces blanches sur un fond noir et en
bas vous verrez des pièces noires sur un
fond blanc votre perception est juste
mais en réalité c'est faux les pièces du
haut et du bas sont rigoureusement le
même couleur je sais de même détester
mais pourtant c'est vrai pourtant c'est
la même chose que sur celui-ci vous êtes
convaincu que le petit carré là avec le
a de noter et plus clair que la surface
notait B et encore une fois c'est votre
cerveau qui s'est parfaitement s'adapter
la réalité c'est que A et B les deux
carrés sont rigoureusement de la même
couleur
[Musique]
prend la forme d'un point levé le geste
des manifestations par exemple la
troisième elle prend la forme d'une
sorte de claquement de doigts et la
quatrième une sorte de pistolet
imaginaire quand on est enfant et qu'on
se tire dessus et peut-être ça va
réveiller dans votre mémoire épisodique
des sons liés à des souvenirs qui sont
appelés juste par la forme des mains que
vous venez de voir cette culture de
Daniel firmant pourrait par exemple
déclencher deux environnements sonores
dans votre esprit soit activé des
souvenirs de désespoir de de tristesse
intense alors peut-être que là vous
entendez des sanglots ou alors plus
probable vous rappeler la position qu'on
prend quand on joue à cache-cache au
point d'entendre le décompte ou quand on
fait 1 2 3 soleil votre cerveau est
associative donc il va activer des
populations de neurones qui contiennent
des souvenirs équivalents à cette
position pourquoi parce que votre
cerveau veut toujours savoir en
permanence dans quelle situation vous
vous trouvez pour faire une sorte
d'analyse des dangers potentiels et donc
là il reconnaît quelque chose que vous
savez que vous connaissez par cœur on
cache le regard pour démontrer aux
autres qu'on ne voit pas pourquoi parce
que on est dans une situation de jeu et
là vous commencez à entendre un décompte
dans votre tête pour ma part ça
fonctionne incroyablement bien avec
cette sculpture magnifique de Maxi Jean
position détendu visage relâché
paupières fermées la bouche en trouverte
aucune tension j'entends presque son
souffle une profonde expiration ça
active mes neurones miroirs et du coup
j'ai envie de respirer aussi
profondément moi aussi en fait plus je
l'observe plus je sens ma pression
artérielle baissée et plus moi aussi
j'ai envie de me mettre dans cet état là
de
et ça doit vous le faire aussi votre
cerveau aime entendre des bruits qui
n'existent pas pour apporter une
cohérence à ce qu'il voit ce qu'il vit
et parfois les mêmes capables de créer
un bruit d'explosion sans veille revenir
dans quelques secondes alors autant le
cerveau aime bien se créer des illusions
auditives autant parfois c'est d'autres
personnes qui se jouent de nos oreilles
volontairement la gamme de chezpard
c'est une illusion auditive bien connue
des musiciens et elle a rendu fou plus
d'une personne quand la découverte
Robert Sheppard c'est un scientifique
qui est spécialisé dans la psychologie
cognitive il a créé une gamme musicale
qui donne l’illusion de monter donc de
plus en plus aigu ou de descendre de
plus en plus grave en tout cas ça ne
s'arrête jamais et en réalité la gamme
de Shepard ne cesse pas de monter
indéfiniment parce que ça c'est
impossible c'est simplement la
superposition de tous les octaves d'une
même note quand on monte la gamme les
notes les plus aigus disparaissent
progressivement pour laisser place aux
notes graves et ça dans une espèce de
boucle sur elle-même qui n'en finit pas
et c'est exactement le même principe que
l'escalier de Penrose vous avez vu
Inception vous savez de marche pas cette
illusion vous l'entendez bien plus
souvent que vous pensez quand vous
regardez un film par exemple dans une
scène de course-poursuite en voiture le
l'ingénieur du son va mettre du moins le
monteur sonore on va dire il va mettre
des sons de moteur qui accélèrent pour
accroître la tension mais comme un
moteur ne peut pas accélérer en
quotidien une perpétuellement les
monteurs sont utilisent le moment où le
conducteur fait un passage de vitesse
pour redescendre le son d'un coup et
ensuite prendre le temps de le remonter
c'est exactement le même principe faites
le test pour voir et comptez le nombre
d'accélérations dans une séquence de
films vous pouvez parfois compter
jusqu'à 15 passages de vitesse ça fait
beaucoup hein la plupart des voitures
elles en ont que 5 des fois 6 allez 7
max il y a le compositeur Hans Zimmer
aussi qui s'insère beaucoup dans le film
Dunkerque de Christopher Nolan je vous
parlais de l'inception tout à l'heure il
a utilisé la gamme de Shepard pour
apporter une tension constante sur une
très longue durée donc ça ça sert aussi
d'une manière artistique et maintenant
si je vous dis Yanni ou Laurel bon avec
un petit accent Yanis
peut-être vous connaissez cette illusion
auditive qui a mondialement créé le
débat sur la toile comme disent les
personnes vieilles comme moi il s'agit
de l'enregistrement audio d'une voix
d'une personne qui prononce un mot qui
peut être entendu comme Yanni ou Laurel
Lowell un petit peu avec le r à
l'anglaise c'est en fonction de la
perception de chaque personne s'est
illusion peut être renforcée
cognitivement si une tierce personne
mime les labiales c'est à dire si vous
entendez ce son avec l'image de
quelqu'un qui fait vous allez entendre
plus facilement gagné si la personne
accélère elle fait
vous allez entendre plus facilement
Laurel Lowell le clip audio créé par un
étudiant en première année de
l'université a suscité à un énorme
intérêt pour les scientifiques qui ont
étudié les mécanismes du traitement
auditif dans le cerveau humain le mot
Laurel contient des fréquences basses
tandis que le mot Yanni a des fréquences
plus hautes donc certaines personnes
entendent plus facilement les fréquences
basses et d'autres entendent mieux les
fréquences aiguës ou les fréquences
hautes parce qu'avant on peut commencer
par l'oeuvre de Tony battelli cet homme
et à quelques centimètres à peine du sol
regardez la chute de sa tête et vous
aurez instantanément l'impression
d'entendre le son du choc comme un bruit
sourd parce que même s'il ne touche pas
le sol votre cerveau la capacité
d'anticiper le son qui va et qui peut
arriver mais ça dépend où vous vous
concentrez d'ailleurs si vous concentrez
plus sur le corps vous allez plus
percevoir des éléments autour de cette
lévitation mais plus vous allez regarder
sa tête et le bas de ses cheveux plus
vous allez pressentir la chute le choc
et le bruit du choc ce qui me permet de
vous parler du fameux syndrome de la
tête qui explose alors pas de danger il
y a pas de douleur c'est un trouble du
sommeil que vous avez peut-être déjà
vécu ça peut arriver au moment de la
transition entre la veille et le sommeil
les personnes qui sont atteintes de ça
en temps au moment de s'endormir le
bruit d'un choc a surdissant comme une
porte qui claque ou un coup de feu dans
la tête c'est incroyable pour certains
c'est même chronique il deviennent même
terrifiés à l'idée même d'aller se
coucher parce que c'est insupportable de
ressentir ça la professeur Isabelle
arnuf neurologue à l'hôpital de la
Salpêtrière racontait un jour qu'un de
ses patients entendaient une grosse
explosion tous les soirs avant de se
coucher alors il pensait qu'il
s'agissait de ses voisins qui claquaient
la porte trop fort et leur a écrit un
mot pour qu'ils arrêtent ils ont pas
arrêté il s'est fâché avec eux jusqu'au
jour où il a entendu exactement le même
bruit alors qu'il ne dormait pas du tout
chez lui il était même dans une autre
ville les causes de cette illusion
auditive sont pas encore clairement
définies par la science mais les
recherches montrent néanmoins que le
stress et l'anxiété ça paraît logique
ont un rôle à jouer dans ce syndrome on
va enchaîner avec les oeuvres de John de
Andréa comme celle-ci et d'autres de Sam
jings pour le mentaliste que je suis on
a ici des exemples frappants de langage
non verbal qui rendent les œuvres encore
plus réalistes on attribut malgré nous
un état émotionnel parce que notre
cerveau a l'habitude de décoder malgré
lui des postures et des gestes qui va
ensuite interpréter peut-être légèrement
penchée le regard baissé fait une petite
moue avec sa bouche l'artiste a choisi
de croiser ses bras les censément
naturellement fermer mais relâché sans
aucune tension et regarder ses épaules
on peut sentir le poids de son corps
relâché tous l'indique une forme de
mélancolie une forme de tristesse
peut-être l'artiste a anticipé ce que
notre cerveau va interpréter sa
fonctionne mon cerveau est en train
justement de rentrer en empathie avec
cette sculpture et de ressentir ce que
l'artiste a souhaité que je ressente en
amont lors de sa création c'est un peu
incroyable replier sur elle-même visage
caché dans le creux de ses genoux les
doigts un peu crispés c'est incroyable
de constater que sans entendre le
moindre son sans avoir la moindre
interaction avec avec la matière
inanimée qui se trouve à côté de nous
notre cerveau va quand même déclencher
automatiquement une interprétation
émotionnelle de ce qu'il voit alors que
je veux dire rationnellement je sais que
c'est pas quelque chose de vivant que
c'est une sorte d'objet et pourtant ça
fonctionne pour celle-ci on va faire
l'inverse je serai très curieux de lire
dans les commentaires ce que vous vous
ressentez ce que vous interprétez quand
vous la regardez alors il y a pas de
mauvaise réponse ça dépend de chaque
personne ça dépend de ce que vous avez
vécu de ce que vous ressentez de ce que
vous voyez de peut-être même de l'état
émotionnel dans lequel vous êtes
actuellement donc vous la regardez vous
me dites ce que vous vous percevez ce
que vous ressentez et on comparera un
peu avec vos différentes réponses dans
les commentaires
[Musique]
on va parler de l'illusion de l'émotion
je suis à côté du neuvre de Evan Penny
et cette œuvre-là est très perturbante
parce que déjà souvent en se positionne
on a l'impression d'aller me fixe du
regard elle est très très réaliste c'est
le cas de le dire alors que pourtant on
voit bien que la taille du visage est
disproportionnée l'arrière du buste et
aplatie c'est très perturbant en fait
quand on en prend conscience nous quand
on s'approche pourquoi ça nous fait tout
ça maintenant je voudrais vous parler
des neurones miroir qui joue un rôle
majeur dans le déchiffrage de la
compréhension des sentiments de ceux qui
nous entourent ils permettent de se
mettre à la place d'une personne des
autres personnes c'est la base de
l'empathie en réalité c'est ce qui
permet d'adopter un consciemment les
mêmes expressions que nos interlocuteurs
et de ressentir leurs émotions si on
voit par exemple un visage triste le
cerveau active une sorte de miroir
facial on reproduit ce visage triste
pour comprendre l'autre on adopte donc
par mimétisme un visage triste et par
conséquent on ressent cette émotion on
ressent la tristesse les œuvres
hyperréalistes qu'on découvre simulent
des émotions qui activent nos neurones
miroirs afin que nous les ressentions
comme si elles étaient véritables comme
si c'était du vrai et c'est pour cette
raison qu'on peut imaginer dans un
potentiel à venir ressentir de
l'attachement et de l'émotion pour je
sais pas moi des robots humanoïdes comme
de la série real humans parce que notre
cerveau ne fait pas la différence entre
le véritable et la simulation grâce ou à
cause des neurones miroirs d'ailleurs
cette notion du vrai ou du faux par
rapport au numérique c'est l'une des
choses sur le laquelle l'artiste qui a
créé cette œuvre veut nous pousser à
réfléchir
le travail d'hyperréalisme est tellement
réussi les détails sont tellement
travaillés que notre cerveau ne
distingue pas l'humain de l'objet
comment c'est possible il y a plusieurs
raisons mais l'exemple que je préfère
c'est celui des bébés pourquoi on est si
attendri par eux regardez les petits
bébés recroquevilliers sur le ventre
avouez que cette image est touchante
elle nous inspire la fragilité la
vulnérabilité elle est veille en nous
l'instinct de protection pourquoi vous
me direz peut-être parce que tout ce qui
est petit est mignon c'est pas faux mais
c'est pas vrai non plus les petites
araignées ça suscite rarement latin de
glissement par exemple les raisons sont
moins poétiques l’œil par exemple c'est
le seul élément externe du cerveau
auquel il est relié bien sûr mais c'est
un bout de cerveau et c'est le seul
organe qui ne grandit pas avec l'âge
autrement dit nous avons dès notre
naissance la taille initiale de nos yeux
c'est pour cette raison que les
mammifères bébé que ce soit les humains
les chats les chiens tous les autres ont
des grands yeux et au cours de
l'évolution nous nous sommes habitués
donc à voir des êtres aux grands yeux
comme des nourrissons à protéger notre
cerveau fait donc un raccourci avec ce
qui est tout ce qui a des grands yeux
nous procure une émotion positive et là
pour les deux bébés qui assure le ventre
des réactions sont finalement binaires
soit vous êtes attendrie directement et
vous avez envie de les protéger soit
vous avez un rejet complet avec une
sorte de gêne parce que votre cerveau
sait que ce n'est pas vrai et du coup il
y a une sorte de dissonance dans votre
instinct de protection
c'est incroyable le travail des artistes
qui ont fait ces œuvres d'hyperréalisme
ce qui est fascinant avec toutes les
œuvres qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est que
on peut on peut ressentir des choses et
ça nous échappe complètement on a beau
savoir qu'il s'agit d'une sculpture et
pas d'une personne réelle on peut pas
s'empêcher de rentrer en empathie de
voir des choses non réelles d'entendre
des sons qui n'existent pas ou même de
ressentir des émotions qu'on maîtrise
pas et c'est là toute la beauté du œuvre
quelle qu'elle soit être saisie être
pris et te transporter par une émotion
une sensation malgré nous cette culture
là c'est l'une de mes préférées parce
que je trouve que cette dame elle est
touchante elle est sympa j'ai clairement
envie de lui faire confiance mais
pourquoi bizarrement elle ne me gêne pas
alors que c'est une personne nue avec
des yeux un petit peu délirants sans
doute parce que tout m'indique dans la
position de son corps et des muscles en
action sur son visage que c'est une
absurdité c'est une farce je peux
presque entendre le bruit que ferait sa
bouche si elle expulsait l'air d'un coup
qui a dans ses joues je voudrais prendre
aussi une seconde pour remercier
vraiment très fort le Musée d'Art de
Nantes de nous avoir accueilli pour
cette vidéo de l'exposition
hypersensible et tout simplement
incroyable si vous avez l'occasion
d'aller la voir vraiment court rési elle
s'arrête en septembre 2023 ça vous
laisse encore un peu de temps j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance de pouvoir filmer les
oeuvres et tourner cette vidéo aussi
alors merci au Musée d'Art de Nantes et
surtout merci à tous les artistes pour
cette expérience qu'on a pu vivre le
truc un peu marrant c'est que si je me
mettais au milieu de la salle ici sans
bouger je parie qu'il y a des visiteurs
qui me prendraient pour une sculpture
peut-être même qu'on me trouverait moins
réaliste que les autres alors dans le
doute j'ai pas le tenter merci d'avoir
regardé à très bientôt Ciao